how's it going with mine him spear too
bad
welcome back to sexy ass slapping whoa
it's so loud on these headphones holy
[ __ ] this is a place Ladner video
playing it's a P right now alright all
this [ __ ] this game got updated and they
added some new stuff to it and I want to
check it out so let's say let's watch em
bad believably I like that he keep
something in it and I'm ready to call a
game at the Predacon game let's go
[ __ ] we meet again what I can't hear you
is so loud it runs a lot so we're better
now actually like I whip my hair back in
for I write my opinion why can't I write
my
it is so [ __ ] loud holy [ __ ] what's
going on here hold it what what what
what's going on here
what is this what what happened they
shut that I like this
anybody out there no huh okay this looks
pretty good
what is this I wouldn't have it
optimisations
that's fine brothers thefinebros oh [ __ ]
let's put on our gas man he might be
here
no I'm backing up backing up backing
that back enough it's my daddy taught me
good
Oh baby baby baby huh
like a baby it's headphones how's it so
loud I should play with this on my
computer I'll [ __ ] die of applause
shut up shut your mama's [ __ ] all right
how do you like quick say f1 all right I
got to do that [ __ ] all right slender
whatever I don't care what your name it
I got to find a security passes yeah man
oh [ __ ] yeah man that's slander
am I still in the camera area I don't
know you don't know I don't know we just
didn't get flow I just said a bad word
I'm sorry Shampoo call I can't stand
more item you can't carry more items
it's it rind all right okay tear gas
what is this a radio what mommy's are
you when do I use this oh not this room
this room is literally impossible
without a flashlight Hey
hi your day oh [ __ ] everything scares
me so [ __ ] loud all right let's go in
here
hi yeah darwin how you doing how you
doing how are you doing
don't be here don't be yeah
Hey not ever Oh what hacks computers
and I didn't do anything Oh what is this
level one all right cool let's go to
that are you in here
what was that sound what is this alright
hope please work please work please work
please work please like please why place
why place why yeah wha-what is this well
what's going on here but I don't think
this is supposed to be what I'm stuck I
think he made a little bag we found a
little bag
all right all right all right all right
all right all right all right we're fine
all right and here we found the key card
yep go away battery we don't need you
off with the gas mask I want to be
badass but not right now
all right here we are hopefully it's not
buggy this time I'm gonna save a bit
more often yeah it's so kind of [ __ ] I
don't know what oh I got through anyway
cool I don't know if it's good or bad
what what is this place what is our
computers servers what is this what
let's put it you two on what what did I
do and why did I do that
oh thank god thank God I'm fine what
fine kids
what are you doing your little pipe [ __ ]
don't try to be piping and [ __ ] I'll pop
your momma if you know what I mean
I don't I'm sorry I said that alright
let's head back I guess I don't know
what I did
[Music]
all right cut the graphics it listen
little buggy because I go through these
[ __ ] walls and [ __ ] but also shit's
not always back yeah now why was that
door red I don't understand anything
like that why do you want from it why do
you want me to slap your ass so bad
[ __ ] hi pirate what are you doing I bet
what you moved of course I'm gonna hug
you but if you hug me you snap my neck
and I'll pound it I love its face it's
so beautiful all right I'm sorry but
what shut up what I need you go where
did he go what what are you doing over
there slapped me patty shut up what stop
what are you oh [ __ ]
all right and then we should probably
get out of here
we're fine we're fine you just wanted to
crack the woman idea what all right
anyway whoa what is this door why don't
you open
okay I gotta click this all right we're
fine we're fine what's fine that's cute
guy we made it we made it everything is
up oh not the tunnels son of a barrel
this one actually oh let do lid off king
kelana cough cough Ilana binky bond over
little dog iPad app if puff puff do four
ain't enough for ding ballot okay I
don't know what I was but again I don't
go to the all right hey what game is
clearly wanting me to go over here what
the hell is going on right now
Oh what more of you what do you want
from me aah what what what is going on
here what is that
ah that's empty the point of this shitty
room I'm out of here
alright fine we'll check this one I bet
it's way cooler what what Morton owes
what about here mark huh knows what I
hate those rooms [ __ ] those rooms [ __ ]
I'm so [ __ ] lost I don't even know
what I'm going to begin with no more
tunnels browse what should i though i
feel scout
I don't know I've been living way too
long right now all right here we go
what is this a book hey my been here
strangely familiar caution that's got to
be fantastic
all right here we go Oh fine right
[Music]
of course of course he's in there
eyedrops [ __ ] what you gonna do what
you gonna do when I'm looking at you
tonight I'd like that
why did you blink I gave you I ravish hi
stupid ass off all right I guess I tried
out all the new stuff I don't know if
there were something else but anyway
like a baby you should enjoy check out
my other recipe videos if you want to
it's your new we should probably are
because everyone is just freaking
streaming anyway man I got hemorrhoids
okay in my vagina
what is back
[Music]